when Connor was saying what he was
saying to you you're listening and
looking at what he's saying and you're
actually internalizing the words why are
you doing that no I like to listen to
people when they talk it's very
interesting because you can listen to
them and you can understand where they
IQ
you understand what I mean
if you are stupid what you can do
you cannot do nothing you have to be
quiet just don't talk in front of a lot
of people because they're gonna
understand who you are it's better don't
talk you know and like I was listening
to him okay maybe he says something like
good things maybe I'm wrong you know
it's like everybody make mistake I was
listening to think these guys like
course this this is I'm like okay this
kind of people they never gonna beat you
this is two different level